today we're going to talk about the
death of cable media it's been slow but
it's now accelerating and three things
that are holding it back from going out
of business today and if one of them
pulled out cable would be done within
seconds
[Music]
okay so if you give value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let's get right into it
yesterday I'm doing a Russell Brand's
podcast and him and I are talking he's
grown now into having millions and
millions of followers and this guy was a
former a-lister oh not the shirt you
know inside of you if you know what I'm
talking about from Forgetting Sarah
Marshall he's an a-lister he's now a
small Media Company getting tens of
millions of eyeballs on a monthly basis
so imagine an a-lister and a former
insurance guy Finance Guy start media
companies and now they're getting more
eyeballs and some traditional mainstream
cable this doesn't make any sense how
big of a disruption is it they should
have never allowed guys like us to get
into it but I'm going to give you
numbers here today for you to be
thinking about all right so let's take a
look at some data last year in July was
a historic month because that was the
first one we're streaming past cable
nobody thought it was going to happen
but it finally happened however look how
dramatically the numbers change from
last July to today we just got the
report from Nielsen I want to show this
to you this is is last year when you
look at this data it shows July 2022
cable
34.4 percent it's the purple line that
you see there and the blue streaming
passed it up 34.8 however if we go look
at the Nielsen report that just came out
last month here's what you'll notice now
you'll see streaming went from 34.8
percent to 38.7 but cable dropped from
34.4 percent to 29.6 and on the
streaming side they got the top of
YouTube then Netflix then Hulu then
Prime video then Disney max 2B peacock
Roku Paramount Pluto the point is you're
no longer watching cable so the same
with cable TV is being disrupted the
therapy industry is being disrupted why
because for many years people didn't
want to go see a therapist because they
were embarrassed of sitting in a waiting
room and they're waiting for meeting the
person and the co-workers is oh you're
coming here too yes is everything okay
I need to talk to somebody I'm saying
now you can use a comp company which is
today's sponsored better hop on your
phone to talk to any therapist and if it
doesn't work out for you they'll replace
it for you at no charge and have another
person working with you got 20 25 000
different people to choose from so look
why do I have them as our sponsor here's
why data proves that this is the
Loneliest Americans have been depression
is high because one we have to be around
people to talk to somebody sometimes you
just have to talk to someone to release
it as a man men typically don't do that
a lot if you've never done that with
Better Health this is a one way for you
to get started to talk about your issues
and you never know that could help you
change your life in a major way go to
betterhelp.com forward slash
valuetainment and get a 10 discount on
your first order once you can go to
betterhelp.com forward slash value
tendency to get 10 discount and join the
other two million people that have also
taken advantage of the service you can
also click on the link below to go there
directly and matter of fact if I was to
ask you right now do you watch cable you
may say I do what do you watch on cable
you may say sports only exactly there's
three things that's hold building cable
from being done within seconds one is
people who watch sports number two is
older people that watch news on CNN Fox
MSNBC these are people that like to
consume their news from TV but you know
what the most important one is do you
know what percentage of all cable TV
advertising money comes from Big Pharma
what do you think is that percentage you
think it's five percent you think it's
ten percent Thirty it's a big number 40
50 there's no way Pat is 50. what if I
told you according to statista the
number is 75 of the funding do you
realize two countries are the only ones
that allow big Pharma to advertise us
and New Zealand if a president changed
the law and said big Pharma can no
longer listen no longer advertise on any
kind of cable TV or streaming cable TV
would go out of business like this at
least 90 percent of them would disappear
because where would they get their money
from and all these guys that are paying
5 10 15 million dollars their salary is
gone they got to go figure out a way how
to make the money on podcasting insane
number when you think about 75 but let
me continue with more data for you so
what you're looking at here is number of
people paying for cable and how it's
declining and if you look at 2013 it's a
hundred million and a half it stays
steady and then all of a sudden it goes
to 90 million 2018 then 2020 to have 78
million but something happened called
covid if you remember because I know it
was three years ago it drops from 78
million to 65 million two years later
and now it's 60 and a half million and
they're simply given a projection of
what's going to be happening and they're
being very nice to Cable how it's going
to go from 60 to 56 to 53 to 50 to 47
but you get the idea now meanwhile look
at Ott is over the top like Netflix Hulu
membership type of things look what it's
done from 2017 till today if you look at
2017 you'll see
72.59 billion so it went from 72.59
billion to 2022 260 billion dollars it's
projected to be at around 400 billion
dollars by 2027 again this is not good
news for cable but let's continue so
here's another question for you how many
streaming services memberships do you
have is it just one some tells me got
more than one 86 percent of us you and I
have more than one streaming service
subscription check this out here only 14
of Americans subscribe to only one 38
subscribe to two twenty seven or three
twelve percent to four nine percent of
you watching this have five or more
you're paying for on a monthly basis
good for you by the way so now when
we're looking at cable you may be saying
it's dead based on what the stuff you'll
show me here I know but let's take a
look at a couple other Industries on how
gradually it happened and why this one
is accelerating let's take a look at
newspapers first the end of newspapers
began in 1990s with the rise of the
internet five signs of why newspapers
decline number one internet number two
the decline of advertising Revenue
number three the changing demographics
of readership number four the rise of
social media number five the increasing
cost of news production so matter of
fact let's just bring it back to you how
many people you know that actually read
a newspaper I know one person in this
building reads a newspaper and it's me
because I read the Wall Street Journal I
actually love it I like to come to my
office open it up read what's going on
because I like doing that right that's a
habit I've had in financial services but
how many people you know yourself if you
do take a picture there ain't too many
of them you know how people consume
their news nowadays Twitter it's your
social media you got internet site
podcasts you got streaming services and
last but not least it's cable which we
know what direction cable is going next
one is landlines when's the last time
you made a phone call with a landline
I'm actually serious we were actually
talking here I can't tell you I I can't
remember the last time I made a phone
call literally I couldn't tell you it's
got to be 2009 the last time I made it
when's the last time you made it what
happened to landlines check this out
with this data so this is 2008 till
today ready 2008 the the green is
landline the blue is cell phones look at
green 80 of us had a landline today it's
28 in 2008 less than 20 had a cell phone
today it's 71 matter of fact don't you
wonder what the other 29 is doing
without a cell phone they have to be
either six years old they have to to be
either 93 years old but what do they do
not having a cell phone well look what
happened to landlines at one point
everybody had it like this massive
disruption disappeared so what caused it
let's take a look one cell phones became
affordable convenient reliable it was
Game Over cost of landlines versus
unlimited clown plans then features of
mobile phones text messaging internet
access apps game over I remember I had
an extell and it wasn't unlimited all of
a sudden my phone bill would be 600 a
month I'm a salesperson so I was like
coming up in business then Nextel came
out with unlimited plan 199 a month it
was insane then somebody else said 149
The Next Step came back 99 and then
nobody cares about unlimited anymore you
can make as many calls as you want but
it's been a massive disruption so here's
another one music how do you consume
your music what do you listen to do you
listen to YouTube iTunes Spotify do you
remember this thing back in the days
that cavemen used to listen to was
called the disc CD do you remember that
check this out with the numbers seal
what it's looking like and how they
peaked in the massive drop-off according
to statista in 19 1983 is when you'll
see compact discs being sold and by the
way the data here is by the millions
okay so it goes and it peaks in the
2000s nearly a billion disks sold every
single year but very quickly it went all
the way back down to today when's the
last time you bought a CD and you work
out with a disc can you imagine you go
to the gym and you see somebody with a
you know the old discolors we would run
it with skip do you remember that where
you would kind of try to run without if
you're 40 you know exactly what I'm
talking about that doesn't belong
anywhere today because we listen to our
music and work out like this of course
unless if your name is Vincent oshana
you still listen to discs so if you look
at this your podcast popularity
percentage of people in the US 12 plus
ever listen to a podcast back in 2006 it
was around 11 today it's 55 and the
number if you look at according to
statista that number the 11 number that
is now 55 57 it's 162 million people
listening to podcasts right now you know
what that's doing this has had a whole
conversation started with Russell Brand
and myself sister business guy Finance
guy podcast getting more eyeballs than
many of these guys on TV what happened
there it's what you call a massive
disruption taking place to cable so look
we talked about how newspapers got
replaced by the internet we talked about
landlines by cell phones CD players by
iPhone cable by streaming and you see
what podcasters are doing today this is
not going away and it's led to the
Creator economy which means you get to
choose who you want to listen to today
back in the days the only people that
were able to get on the big screen TV
that had to do a lot of favors they have
to be related to somebody that had to be
connected with somebody you couldn't it
didn't mean they were the best people
it's just those were the people that got
the job because they knew somebody it
meant maybe the best person was out
there but didn't have a way of getting
to know the guys so they never Excel to
the top if that makes any sense today
the market is wide open whoever is the
best Rises to the top competition Galore
who wins the audience wins because you
get to pick and choose who you want to
watch by which videos you like and if
you don't like it you don't pay for it
you go to a different Channel that's
real competition finally we have some of
that confidence National media and FYI
with cable we're going to talk about the
creative economy on another video and
what kind of money is being made and
what's the possibilities out there and
what direction it's going but here's
what we have to know here with cable old
folks it's a timeline okay I'm 44. I
ain't gonna live forever you ain't gonna
live forever old folks watching news
they're not going to be living forever
so what is that timeline right they're
10 years 20 years 30 years okay but
let's set that aside Sports who's
starting to pick up Sports deals a lot
of these streamers do you know how scary
that is if these guys start signing up
with them and if some basketball teams
are now doing their own streaming their
own Ott wait a minute what if every MLB
team every NHL team that's a scary
thought of course it is that's the
direction it's gone well one Noble law
by candidate a president who comes out
and says moving forward in America big
Pharma can no longer advertise on TV or
streaming services 75 of cable TV money
goes away what do you think they're
gonna do they're already struggling how
do they make their money they would have
to revamp their entire business model
and that's massive revamping to be done
so if I were you and you were thinking
about investing into a cable TV stock
I'm not giving you a new advice even I'm
a financial advisor series seven I'm
telling you this is not advice I'm just
telling you you may want to think twice
about it because the game is changing in
a very very Major Way having said that
if you got value out of this video give
it a thumbs up subscribe to the channel
I got another video I want you to watch
on the subscription industry and what
it's done the size of it if you've never
seen it click here to watch it take
everybody bye-bye bye-bye
foreign